ونتابع معكم اعداد الرحلات الجويه التي
تاثرت بهذا التوقف حتى همم الان
وهمم نشير هنا
بان هذا العطر الفني قد اصاب نظام اداره
الطيران الفيدراليه الامريكيه ويعرف باسم
نوتيم همم والمعلومات الاوليه تتحدث عن
تاجيل نحو 1162 رحله داخل الولايات
المتحده الغاء مئات الرحلات همم الاخرى
همم هذا النظام هو نظام امريكي يغتصب
بالرحلات الجويه لا يمكن لاي طائره ان
تقلع من المدرجها قبل الحصول على اشعار
رسمي من هذا النظام يفيد بان الطائره
مامونه ثلاثيا همم لاستهدافها من قبل اي
دوله اخرى ولكي كذلك لا تتقاطع مع طائره
اخرى في نفس الارتفاع
والمسار همم الجوي وقد دخل الخدمه في 19
47 لم يحدث له اي عطل ربما حتى الان
باستثناء ما حدث بها 2,000 وواحد في احداث
همم 11 من سبتمبر هذه الاحداث التي عطلت
التيارات
لفتره من الوقت متابع الان مع مراسلتنا من
واشنطن ريتا سليمان هل من جديد
[موسيقى]
في المطارات ولكن ليس بالاقلاع ولكن حتى
اللحظه ليس من الواضح عدد الرحلات الجويه
همم تاثرت حتى هذه الساعه المبكره هنا
وذلك لانه بعد شركات طيران قد تكون قادر
على العمل بدون معلومات من النظام
والمعروف بس النظام همم
كانت همم الطيران ذكرت ان الفنيون حاليا
يعملون على استعاده النظام ولا يوجد تقدير
محدد للوقت الذي يمكن استعاده الخدمه